the world's oceans make up the largest
habitat on the planet and they contain
one of our most vital sources of food
fish
and we eat a lot of it
[Music]
the average human being consumes around
45 pounds of fish every year and for
over 3 billion people it's their primary
source of protein global demand for
seafood is rising fueling a
multi-billion dollar commercial fishing
industry but experts warn that in some
places these commercial vessels are
catching more fish than the ocean can
provide threatening sea life and the
very people who rely on the ocean the
most
according to the united nations there
are over 370 million indigenous people
around the world
along the world's coastlines there are
more than 27 million indigenous people
spread across at least 87 countries
and for many of these coastal
communities the ocean has been vital to
their culture and survival for thousands
of years so coastal indigenous peoples
is a group that really encompasses a lot
of different types of communities
sometimes entire nations it's something
that's not an official definition it's
something that we use sort of as a
shorthand for indigenous communities
that uh still live on on coastlines one
defining aspect that we see again and
again is an incredibly close
relationship with seafood just the
practice of fishing has a lot of
cultural significance right so even
though
yes they rely a lot on fish for local
food security and nutrition
even just the practice of going out is a
way in which they share stories
communicate knowledge and really kind of
further the traditions
the hustic nation is one of the largest
tribes on the central coast
we are a marine community
we're located you know right you know
the ocean is right in front of us we
live in a really remote area
and it's very isolated and it's very
costly to get you know groceries up here
so our sustenance in our way of life has
been to harvest salmon spawn on kelp
crabs
bronze
seaweed our bread basket is the ocean
[Music]
typically this is a man or woman but
mostly men
go fishing using the traditional conway
and who live mainly on
fishing the vase has been there for
centuries and they've been transmitting
their
techniques from generation to generation
this is um for the vessel i think the
main source of uh
lively woods and also income for the
family the simplest one we use the
simplest gears
that could be spears and or maybe pollen
line
while the rich ones can go and buy nets
and that they will be using those nets
depending on where they are on the
coastline they can catch like octopus
around the
reef also they can catch squid tuna
and lobster mostly they are catching
small pelagic fish
[Music]
today coastal indigenous people consume
around 15 times more fish than
non-indigenous people and many rely
heavily on seafood as a source of income
but in recent years they've been forced
to compete with large-scale commercial
fishing vessels capable of catching
several tons of fish per day
commercial fisheries at industrial scale
are
relatively recent right obviously we've
been fishing for a long long time but
when we really see fisheries sort of
globally ramp up
is you know from the 1950s
british columbia home of the world's
largest salmon fleets hits the
fisherman's jackpot a 5 million dollar
catch
nets one-third of a mile long are
dropped around a school of fish and the
hauling inn begins there's really two
different main kinds one is the the
national industrial vessels right so a
lot of countries have their national
commercial fishing fleets and that often
is kind of the first source of conflict
where you have these larger boats
they're operating locally but they're
have much more capacity than indigenous
communities have right and so that's a
big source of competition
another one that's relatively more
recent are distant water fisheries these
are primarily from eastern asia western
europe these are fleets that go all over
the world and they have enormous impacts
not only for indigenous peoples but also
for just the countries where they're
operating
probably the most direct way that this
is impacted is obviously through
overfishing of their shared stocks but
also through crowding out of what used
to be traditional indigenous areas
places where we saw these traditional
area-based protections or particular
rules about when to fish and how and
what
a lot of these commercial vessels don't
have any respect for that sort of thing
and so that has
caused a lot of conflict and tension
according to a united nations report the
marine commercial fishing sector brought
in over 186.1
billion pounds of fish and shellfish in
2018. while estimates vary it's believed
that around one in every five fish sold
are caught by vessels engaged in illegal
unreported and unregulated fishing
activity each year there's a significant
amount of non-compliance out there
globally and not just distant water
fleets just generally throughout the
fishing industry you could have minor
offenses up to what we call serious
infringements a minor offence could be a
mistake on a logbook up to a serious
infringement we could be
significant fishing over quota
without a license
without authorization and those are
generally the dark vessels that we talk
about which can do significant damage
and harm penalties and sanctions for
fisheries offenses can generally tend to
be quite low and if you're making
millions and millions of pounds in
illegal fishing
it's worth breaking the law and there
are some
organized fisheries crime syndicates
that will factor these types of fines
into their activity almost as if it's a
business cost
many of these vessels use a variety of
techniques to skirt the law and avoid
detection but modern technology is
helping governments and coastal
communities protect their waters from
this type of fishing
so this is done through the use of
remote sensing so satellite technology
we use a varying range of sensors with a
different degree of resolution and they
help us to detect vessels that either
fish at night by detecting the lights
or fishing during the day
and we can task and focus these
satellites in areas of interest the
intelligence information that comes from
that is then given to our partners in
government
and they use that to task their patrols
and surveillance succeed for fisheries
enforcement
one of the problems with vessels on the
high seas is that they're technically a
piece of that nation's land at sea let's
just say it's a madagascar flagged
vessel and it's a uk fisheries
protection vessel you would need to get
permission from the madagascar
authorities to board that vessel in high
seas
and so some of the techniques are a
constant changing of flag which means
that you never know which nation you're
supposed to be asking permission or
you'll go to one and it turns out
they've moved to another at which point
you're running out of fuel you've got to
go you're hundreds of miles from land
the the true dark vessels the iuu
vessels
will use fixers
in ports so they can land their illegal
catches we see all sorts so misreporting
of catches i say i caught it here and
then we've actually seen them fishing
somewhere completely differently we see
it a lot on boundaries a territorial
waters boundary for example but also on
marine protected areas there are buffer
zones around marine protected areas and
you will see a vessel sitting right on
the outside of that
pointing in a certain direction that you
can be pretty confident that the net is
probably inside the area often the key
thing is they will switch off their
tracking systems so this is the ais the
automatic identification system or
they'll spoof so they can put another
vessel's ais system on their vessel or
they can actually name themselves
something completely different
it's not necessarily uh that these
vessels are not licensed or or
authorized and there have been some
countries in the past that have made a
significant amount of money from
opening up their licenses and so there
are various states flags of convenience
they're called which will open up their
licenses and their waters to these
vessels without consideration of the
smaller communities that rely on the
water and the fish
[Music]
the reason that a lot of these fisheries
the distant water fisheries are able to
operate far from their own ports is
because of government subsidies these
are governments paying for fuel for
bigger boats for maintenance but there
was one recent study that found that
if you took those subsidies away about
of those distant water fleets wouldn't
be profitable most countries if not all
countries subsidize their fisheries in
in some way there will be
fishing vessels that will be fishing in
a non-compliant manner that are in
receipt of subsidies
there are signs
of over-exploitation we heard testimony
from the people saying that you know
once those big vessels are around
there's no more left to fish and they
are forced to go further offshore which
is quite dangerous for the vessel the
trawlers are destroying under the
habitats they are destroying the coral
reef dragging all around and with the
fish it's quite difficult to
provide a certain estimate of what
they've been losing what we hear from
the elder is that they used to be bigger
size of catch in terms of fish and now
it's less and less and the most of the
cast today is very small there's a big
impact for the vessel
especially on the lively woods and the
food security issue
you know some of our elders have talked
about going out onto the fishing grounds
that there are so many boats out on the
fishing grounds
at night time it looked like a virtual
city out on the ocean our communities
can no longer access salmon as a
reliable
and abundant food source we do a lot of
our own research here our nation has
experienced a decline
up to 85 percent in the salmon
and that has had devastating effects you
know on our community we attribute this
decline
to
fishing and that includes sports and
recreational it also includes other
human activities as well that you know
includes the effects of climate change
we really feel that you know we're
you know 10 20 years beyond a crisis
we reached out to canada's department of
fisheries and oceans for comment on this
story they're aware of the significant
decline in salmon along the central
coast and have launched a 647.1 million
effort to stabilize and rebuild stocks
here's what they said this initiative
includes bold transformative steps like
long-term closures of commercial pacific
salmon fisheries and a licensed buyback
program which will permanently remove
fishing effort from pacific salmon
stocks while providing license owners
the opportunity to retire with dignity
to continue to build on our
understanding of pacific salmon stocks a
joint technical committee that includes
central coast first nations and dfo
stock assessment representatives are
currently reviewing central coast salmon
assessments
as coastal indigenous communities try to
combat overfishing they're also dealing
with the issue of climate change and
these two issues are deeply intertwined
one of the big dangers when you combine
overfishing and climate change impacts
on coastal indigenous communities is
that
you know these ways of life will be lost
for good you know on the one hand you
have these very very large very
globalized commercial fishing fleets
that are just falling fish wherever
they're moving to and then you have
these habitat impacts of climate change
we're messing with food chains we're
messing with habitats we are releasing
so much gas into the atmosphere and now
we're starting to see significant
impacts on our oceans we're starting to
see reductions in fish stocks you get
impacts on mangroves on coral reefs
on sea ice
and and those are places where
indigenous peoples disproportionately
live around the world in a lot of places
just because of colonial histories many
of these indigenous people's rights are
tied to places
they're even kind of legally in some
ways bound to the place where they are
and so it's very difficult for them to
leave
you know when people aren't able to fish
they they have to move outside of their
communities
it doesn't take long for the language to
be lost for the knowledge to be lost and
that is a loss of culture
it's a part of our dna it's part of who
we are and if we cannot access that
we will lose
part of that identity of what we have
which has sustained us since time and
memorial what the visual will do is to
adapt themselves on the changing
environment that's why they they need
support from every stakeholder to ensure
that they can keep their activities
any of the things that we can do to help
starts with granting them more
sovereignty over the resources right
with the power to decide
what they're using how they're using it
we need to make sure that small scale
fishers local communities are involved
and consulted
in big decisions in high level decisions
regarding phishing agreements or
national policy there is the concept of
locally managed marine areas which is a
concept that was developed in the
pacific in the 90s one of the biggest
issues of the lma managers in madagascar
is the fact that they are
isolated they are marginalized they do
not have any um mean of communication so
that is the reason why those small scale
fishers took the decision to create the
national network it was around 12.
currently
it's around 200
and more communities around the uh the
islands this is to help all those
communities to to join their voice and
to be heard
at that point they become a legally
recognized player in the management
table and that's been something that
hasn't happened historically and it's at
the root of a lot of these issues i do
believe that commercial fishing
co-exists with traditional indigenous
ways of life and actually a lot of
indigenous communities are fully engaged
with commercial fishing they're doing it
themselves i think the important thing
is that we address the power imbalance
that very often is at play between
commercial fishing interests and those
of indigenous peoples
[Music]
you